well Muhammad Jam jum joins us live now
from ashdod in southern Israel near the
border with Gaza Muhammad so Hamas
Rockets hit the southern city of ashkon
yesterday and there are still reports of
sporadic fighting in the South where you
are what more can you tell
us that's right Daren let me first walk
you through uh the reports of the
fighting that we've gotten over the
course of the last few hours um one in
an area called kabut raim another in an
area close to Gaza called kabut melim uh
we were told by the Israeli Army that in
those two incidents there had been
exchange of gunfire in both those areas
between Hamas Fighters and Israeli Army
members and that as a result at least
four Hamas Fighters killed in those
clashes also there are reports from the
Israeli Army of clashes that took place
in the industrial zone of ashalon and
the Israeli Army reports that as a
result of gunfire exchanges between
Hamas Fighters and Israeli Army members
in that industrial Zone of ashalon that
three Hamas Fighters were killed so that
just goes to show how even in the
overnight hours there were continued
reports of a very fluid and volatile
situation you mentioned of course
ashalon yes ashalon was hit by a rocket
fired from Gaza earlier in the day and
even after that even after that incident
which happened yesterday further on in
the evening we were in an area known as
zakim Junction just outside of the area
known as zakim which is about 3 km north
of Gaza in southern Israel
we witnessed rocket fire emanating from
the Gaza Strip most of those Rockets We
Believe were intercepted by Israel's
Iron Dome defense system um but the
rocket volleys continued late into the
evening in the past few hours even
though it's been more quiet here in
ashod where we are than it was earlier
in the evening um we still would hear
occasionally outgoing uh shelling
happening from Israel going towards Gaza
so a very fluid situation very volatile
and continues to be Darren um I'm
Muhammad the Israelis are saying they've
mobilized around 360,000 reservists what
sort of buildup are you seeing on the
ground there in terms of a potential
ground invasion of
Gaza Darren every place we've been in
these areas in the south of Israel you
very much see a a troop buildup a
mobilization a mass mobilization going
on uh every place you stop you see an
increased security presence be they
solders
uh Army members uh police men and women
reservists they are all over the place
uh beyond that when you are on those
roads and highways driving to the South
further to the South approaching the
border with Gaza you see military
equipment being moved you see heavy
machinery being moved you see troops
being moved not just in cars you also
have witnessed something that we've seen
over the course of the past couple of
days a very interesting site on some of
those roadways you see what looks like
kilometers worth of cars that are just
stopped on the side of the road
essentially what that is reservists who
have driven themselves to the South that
are joining up with their units that
have essentially just left their cars on
the side of the road as they join their
fighting groups so that's one of the
reasons why so many of the residents
that we've spoken within these areas the
past few days do believe that an that a
ground invasion of Gaza as they tell us
they believe that it could happen at any
time some of them think that it will
happen imminently and it's one of the
reasons there is so much concern because
people just don't know exactly what the
days ahead have in store for them and
they are quite worried Darren all right
Muhammad Jam Jun lifeus there in ashdod
in the south of Israel thank you
Muhammad